[Music]
it could be months before a civil sex
abuse lawsuit against britain's prince
andrew goes to trial if it ever does but
this morning the british newspapers are
making their own judgments reacting to
queen elizabeth removing her son's
official titles and his honorary
military ranks andrew has also been told
he can no longer call himself his royal
highness this is a stunning rebuke from
buckingham palace because you know it
comes from his mother holly williams has
more on the story
the british monarchy is distancing
itself from prince andrew and the
scandal that's engulfing him a former
helicopter pilot in the royal navy who
saw active service he'll lose more than
a dozen honorary military titles a
decision made with the queen's approval
and agreement in a terse two sentence
statement it follows an anti-monarchy
group releasing this letter yesterday
from 152 british military veterans
demanding he be stripped of all his
military ranks and titles describing the
prince as uncooperative and less than
truthful about his relationship with
jeffrey epstein that friendship has
tarnished the reputation of the queen's
second son for over a decade now he's
being sued by virginia defray who
alleges she was trafficked by epstein to
prince andrew and that he sexually
assaulted her multiple times when she
was a teenager
the prince denies the allegations and
has not been charged with any crime
i have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady he made that claim in 2019
despite this photograph that appears to
show them together with his friend
convicted sex trafficker glenn maxwell
whatever happens in the court case even
if he's able to clear his name
in court
he's still not coming back to frontline
duties ever because he is so damaged in
the public eye because his reputation is
so damaged in the public eye not just in
the uk but around the world the york
brand is now toxic
statement from the palace also said that
prince andrew is defending the sexual
assault lawsuit as a quote private
citizen and to give you a sense of how
humiliating all of this is for prince
andrew some of the british newspapers
this morning are openly mocking him
thrown out says this one pun intended
and the narcissist formerly known as
prince
gail oh ouch holly williams because
you're in london you get the papers you
get the chatter from the people in the
streets what are they saying about the
queen's decision do they are they
applauding it do they
do you hear anything about how difficult
this was for her because it's always
been widely reported that andrew is her
favorite son
i think that there's a lot of anger and
a lot of disgust about this whole
scandal this whole matter when you talk
to people on the streets here but
there's also enormous sympathy for the
queen because they know that he's her
son he's reported to be her favorite son
and after all she just lost her husband
last year and this is you know her
jubilee year it's supposed to be a time
of celebration
yes and at the end of the day it is
still her son thank you very much holly
williams reporting from london